non mais je suis tellement une quiche en
dragon n'a pas des trucs qui marche à
tous les coups toi bah moi non mais par
contre williams a fait une trentaine de
vidéos sur sa chaîne youtube avec des
conseils excellent pour amener le plus
de filles possible dans son livre avant
d'aller à aborder les femmes et bien
évidemment il faut il faut avoir pris 7
merci oui y'a jamais tout le monde ça
fait 20 ans que j'ai pas pris de douche
[ __ ] wyss a joué que les femmes c'est
bon maintenant que les femmes adorent
les chemises et si vous mettez comme le
font la plupart des mecs juste un
t-shirt blanc ça les femmes celles les
attire pas trop mettez des belles
chemises et en plus de couleurs les
femmes sont sensibles à tout ce qui est
couleur vif john lawrence grech ça c'est
bien vrai quand je croise une femme à
chaque fois je lui demande qu'est ce que
tu penses de sa faune au long du salon
j'aime pas du temps le tir en mode aa
assaoui ça j'aime beaucoup le mauve
couleur vive je suis attirée vers cette
couleur vive tel un papillon de nuit
vers la lumière il a plein d'astuces qui
marche à chaque fois faut savoir que
william couche avec des dizaines de
femmes chaque jour sa phrase d'accroché
prague là ça s'approche pour moi qui ai
une phrase vous allez voir ça marche
plutôt très très bien et plus chaud des
meubles comme ça attention ça serait de
dire à la fille bonjour
je m'appelle william j'ai 32 ans je
réside à arcachon je travaille dans
l'immobilier et donc je ne recherche une
copine danger c'est pourquoi j'invite
par cette phrase je me permets juste
d'émettre tout petit bémol je pense que
si tu t'appelles pas william ça ne
marche pas trop après c'est peut-être
moi qui suis un peu étriqué d'esprit
dans cette phrase d'un proche
je la répète bonjour je m'appelle rien
ok ok il insista veut dire que ça marche
comme ça il faut le dire comme ça c'est
tout lui aussi de très bons conseils
très utiles pour les tombeurs séduisant
commune je vous dis qu'il faut enfermer
tous et rendez vous au moins deux heures
à l'avancé parce que si jamais vous fait
trente ou quarante kilomètres pour aller
à ce rendez vous et qu'il a fini à elle
vous aura fait perdre votre temps de
l'argent parce que ça fait dépenser de
l'essence et moralement ça sera pas bien
alors ça c'est un conseil pour les
autres un faiseur de saluer celui jamais
arrivé et lui il a pas besoin d'eux mais
pour vous juste un sms et c'est bon
comme ça au moins on est sûr
alors si elle vous répond ok ça tient
pour le rendez vous continuez votre truc
juste avant de partir vous renvoyer un
deuxième sms je suis en train de partir
est ce que ça tient toujours pour le
rendez-vous d'accord c'est vrai c'est
vrai qu'on n'est jamais trop prudent je
le rappelle encore une fois lui ça lui
est jamais arrivé qu'on le plan et
ensuite pendant le trajet quand vous
est à mi chemin nous arrêter sur le bord
de la route vous envoyer un dernier
petit sms en disant je suis en route
j'arrive bientôt comme ça ça vous évite
de faire 30 40 km pour eux rien d'accord
oui oui c'est vrai que même moi ce que
je fais c'est jouer un 4e sms aux trois
quarts du parcours avec mes coordonnées
gps et mon niveau d'essence comme ça
c'est bien que je suis exactement et je
m'arrête là parce que souvent en 5e sms
elle appelle les flics
pourquoi draguer une fille dans un
quelconque bar où elle passe du bon
temps nul comme ça alors qu'on peut
l'aborder pendant qu'elle achète ses
tampons 5 boutons petits débordements
mais un mois lorsque vous allez au
supermarché n'y allez pas les mains
vides
vous prenez un cali et ça c'est hyper
important à partir du moment où vous
avez un caddie vous allez pouvoir mais
un pack d'eau de d'envoi un pack ne pas
lâcher voilà pourquoi j'adore williams
comme moi et boit pas d'alcool parce que
c'est un homme responsable
mais en même temps il aime bien le goût
de la bière parce que c'est en cours
pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut un caddie
avec du panache et pour draguer sage et
prépa comprennent et fille que vous
allez aborder dans le magasin un
dragueur professionnelle mais c'est
tellement intelligent williams et oui
sacoche paloffis à chaque fois ils me
disent ouais j'ai peur que les hommes
soient des dragueurs professionnelle
dans les magasins comme ça en plus quand
on voit où il ya mme bâ séducteur
chemise de couleur vive qui attire les
femmes csu attention c'est pas le seul
conseil en a plein d'autres ne vous
approchez pas trop près de la fille il
faut garder à peu près on va dire de m
c'est bon je vous avais un peu beaucoup
moins on va vérifier
romain on va mettre une perruque alors
moi ça fait beaucoup
c'est pas c'est pas dingue dingue pour
aborder les femmes c'est peut-être le
jour on a appris la douche me william va
plus loin il est dans le futur faut-il
d'année
béchir dans les magasins bah oui nous
nous le commun des mortels on pourrait
croire que non les caissières elles sont
en train de travailler il ya là que
c'est stressant c'est pas l'endroit mais
pas pour william journée s'est pavanée
disait et à chaque fois que j'ai pu
obtenir un numéro de téléphone d'une
caissière soit c'était un faux numéro
soit elle ne me répondait pas vous avez
vous une seconde là parce que des
williams qui s'est pris un râteau put
alors que le dit si bien william fait de
la pratique de la pratique de la fratrie
williams vous montre gratuitement la
façon dont ils ramènent ces nombreuses
femmes séduisant dans son lit juste pour
vous avec de la pratique à sa peine
commencé vous avez déjà remarqué la
petite caméra miniature utilisé
essentiellement par les espions et les
psychopathes et on est dans son endroit
de prédilection le supermarché lokadi le
panache et le congo gagnant il est comme
un poisson dans l'eau ou la phrase
d'accroché tellement dingue alors fait
tomber son steak chez williams prendra
williams je me suis pas prêt je me suis
pas prêt attendez attendez c'est
forcément l'exception qui confirme la
règle je le sais c'est sûr c'est sur
william hill pécho un maximum de filles
derrière le prouve dans ces vidéos la
peine louisiane sud arcachon déjà fait
aucune faille dans l'immobilier
d'accord je ne comprends pas je ne
comprends pas ce n'est pas possible ce
n'est pas possible tout cas j'aime
beaucoup sa manière de flouter les
visages avec un mot énorme comme ça sur
la gueule williams est aussi un petit
peu expert dans l'art du montage a
forcément une vidéo sur sa chaîne il
chope un numéro c'est pas possible
autrement
si quelqu'un les a faits célibataire je
comprends pas là j'avoue je suis perdu
ce serait la première chaîne de
séduction où il ya que des râteaux quoi
à quoi ça sert je vous conseille
d'acheter ce gilet pare-balles dernier
cri arrête les balles à bout portant la
preuve je regrette je regrette beaucoup
je suivais matin fermé but parallèle
belles dents blanches
du coup je suis curieux de savoir à quoi
ressemble et filles qui drague
d'habitude vous faire une cure et donc
j'ai fait
ben pourquoi pas tenter la banque
cordiaux alors pas encore dit non alors
on s'accroche quasi panache et alors
alors il s'est passé comment on dégoûte
c'était un faux numéro mais non mais non
non non non comme le dit will i am coach
en séduction dans la région de bordeaux
et d'arcachon la théorie c'est bien la
pratique c'est mieux j'ai décidé de
coucher avec des dizaines de jolies
femmes aux belles dents blanches
aujourd'hui avec la méthode williams
c'est parti
bonjour je m'appelle william et j'ai 32
ans je réside à arcachon genre je
m'appelle william et j'ai 32 ans
bonjour je m'appelle william j'ai 32 ans
est investie dans ce william et j'habite
à arcachon où l'a pas trop près nous
dans le moment là là c'est mieux
j'étais célibataire c'est peut-être
numéro je me cherche une copine non je
vous achète des tampons attendions face
à peu ses habitants non je n'en je suis
d'arcachon pas facho super c'était
célibataire sinon ça va redémarrer
je me cherchais une copie nous est jolie
non non c'est ce que j'ai peur du port
du jaune quand même c'est mieux donc je
disais que je cherche une copine jeu là
c'est trop loin là et je suis pas un
dragueur professional jésus jésus pas
lâcher ce que j'adore des coûts liam
c'est qu'il est modeste
à ce jour il a renommé toutes ces vidéos
sur sa chaîne youtube en la première
chaîne de séduction humoristique cercle
il couche avec tellement de femmes
chaque jour que bat pour lui ces
conseils c'est ça la rigolade on si vous
êtes déçue par la méthode nous y sommes
pour des raisons que j'ignore
il faut savoir sur youtube il ya plein
plein plein d'autres qu'on coach coach
en séduction avec d'excellents conseils
d'excellentes phrase d' approche
juan mata parce que je peux vous
enseigner un vieux chien je suis une
petite robe de mariage alors fait c'est
une blague
enfin je travaillais pas ici c'était
juste une excuse pour venir te voir toi
on n'a pas aimé les dinosaures non non
l'a pas aimé d'ailleurs elle envoyait
météorique espérons tirer c'est l'appât
garder mon direct